does this list look familiar these are
numbers we know about right we gave them
labels what are all these guys up here
this one actually should be Kishin it
sorry these guys are the counting
absorber the natural numbers right okay
are these ones these are so they're
inclusive of the natural ohms you get
the integers right these guys okay I
suppose you could say it did - but if I
include all of those it's just good okay
uh what about these guys were they
called they call you rationals right
okay how about these guys in here these
are actually also in this same camp
right they're just little bit different
okay what do you call these
now you could call them irrational but
if you just consider all of these
together right remember we did the Venn
diagram extended these guys are real and
then that leaves us with so I imagine or
if I added other numbers you get the
comics all right now get this okay all
of these numbers together and I think I
think we have fire in there somewhere as
well with vigor we would fife it is fire
natural no is it is it an integer no
it's not rational is it it had been here
wouldn't it I think fire would be here
all of these numbers believe it or not
are all actually part of one big family
and here's your heading for today all of
these numbers are called the algebraic
numbers
algebraic numbers so this is a bit like
if you want to think like ah if you want
to think of biology right you know how
there's like species and then there's
what's above a species a genus which is
is there anything above Jesus what about
you families okay and you're like it's
like me and like you know jellyfish what
are we having comments I will wear
carbon-based or whatever all of these
things they have in common this now why
do you think they're called
like we get why rational numbers are
called rational numbers even to an
extent we get why natural numbers are
called that why are they called
algebraic of Zeppelin okay because all
of these numbers that when you were
creating your expressions what you are
really I didn't tell you this but you
were creating equations right all of
these algebraic numbers you got they're
all solutions I don't know about this
one but you know yeah they're all
solutions to these equations and these
are algebraic equations we use the tools
of algebra right and when you solve
every one of these you'll get an
algebraic number okay now here's the
weird funky thing there are numbers that
don't belong so this set okay and this
is feeding into our next topic of math
error and things that what is math is
math to discover it that was a big
debate point Marla I really loved
reading all the disagreement and anger
and no you're wrong of the discussions
over we have writing their numbers that
don't belong here right that these
numbers are what we've invented this is
what I put to you okay they have been
created and formed and found through
invented means but there are numbers
that aren't in here and I'm going to
give you two actually you kind of know
what they are the first one is the big
that it will absence from here right
what's the big superstar number of
mathematics it's pi it's part now just
consider this with me for a second
where do I come from where is it
contract ready confer yeah good very
close it's about it's about the
circumference so the conference versus
the diameter right so it's a very simple
shape it's very simple shape but you
know if you guys know we're into
thinking deeply about simple things
right so this number this number comes
out of this and guess what
you can't build it anywhere using
algebra it's impossible right if I had
to put it this way a PI is not the
solution sorry that's an abbreviation
Al's transmission to any polynomial
equation that's the fancy way of saying
right you can write any polynomial your
life you guys are seen probably those
before you know you got squares you've
got plus minus fours whatever you like
right there's no pollen you can write
where pi will be one of the solutions or
one of the one of the roots if you were
drawing it back okay now we know what PI
is the other one and I sort of mention
it very briefly is e okay now if you
have your calculator that you can get E
and yeah we have talked about this
briefly and passing before super I don't
want it to here's how we're going to do
I'll show you how we get it and then
you'll see how it's well maybe you'll be
able to work out why it's be okay
put your pens down for a second which
place down I'm gonna give you a metaphor
right and then it'll get us to this
number this strange number okay let me
take you to a bank take you to the bank
okay now if you go to the bank
okay and you say well I'm gonna invest
some money you're going to get interest
back for your money right now I know we
talked about simple and compound
interest but simple interesting that one
really pays signatures so compound
interest what is science reading hey
what is the compound interest formula
here tom it's a
times 1 + through that ok now one of the
pieces pay for principle the amount of
money you're putting that off all right
like percentage and for ya number of
years months whatever now I'm panicking
now so far so good
we're still using algebraic tools okay
now I hope you see you know the amount
that you put in there doesn't matter all
that much it's not that important for
you you can put in $1,000 $5,000 I'm
just going to imagine what if you just
put in $1 okay the reason why is I don't
know if you want it was due a bit of an
experiment okay suppose you have $5,000
what do you think is better putting it
in one bank account with $5,000 or
putting it in 5,000 Vanya's each with a
dollar in them which one is better
no it's kind of funny assuming they have
the same think of the fees MSU means no
fees same interest rate actually there's
no difference oh you can go ahead and
prove it for yourself if you like we can
use this boy southern hark about but for
that reason I'm just going to consider a
dollar because then if you have more
than a dollar it's no big deal
alright now let's suppose is a really
generous place really really really
generous okay and it gives you an
interest rate of 100 percent okay so you
know this bag is this bag is run by
someone with very very deep pockets like
you know saying see me okay obviously my
friend wouldn't be Rubbermaid but
suppose now here's the thing right um if
we put it in for say a year right then
that'll be you know one but actually you
guys know it actually doesn't wait there
sit there for a whole year and then
double right in fact our banks they give
you interest a little more frequent in
that how often
they'll they'll pay you every month but
they actually calculate it every single
day
did you know that now if you if you've
got a baby you can go and log on and you
can see it's like oh cool I earned 3.2
cents today something trivial like that
but happens now being that each day
you're actually getting one little
fraction of the interest this number
changes doesn't it right it's not much
change it it's going to be the contacts
which is 365 okay so therefore I'm
Katherine how much will you have at the
end of the year no seriously how much we
have don't work out you got a calculator
this 100% right it's just one
they're like whoa whoa what did you get
to a point now hold on a second you're
like huh that's a bit that's a bit funny
but wait a second if you know I didn't
do it frequently if I didn't do every
day you just at the end of the you just
get doubled right if you doing every day
you get more what if you did it more
frequently what if you didn't say say
there's 24 hours in the day right so
every hour let's do it every hour right
which means that this is going to be
sung as before right so you wouldn't get
two point seven one four five six seven
anymore will you what do you get you get
more right but how much what do you get
what do you get come on give me some
decimal places on yeah this eight one
two yeah like no more come on how about
not every hour
how about every minute what do you get
what do you get I can tell you now
you're probably gonna get to eight
something something like that okay in
fact what you're going to get is this
something okay now what have we just
done
what we are modeling right now is
something that grows and as it gets
bigger right it grows faster don't make
sense because you know the more money
that's in there the more interesting to
those that's the way compound interest
works if I drew it it would look like
this starting off at $1 yeah it's an e
for exponential curve like this number
this number this is the number of
exponential growth everywhere in the
universe and you can't build it like
this we sort of DIN right but what you
really into it like these things won't
give you this exact number right you
have to keep on doing if you keep on
doing it forever okay so these two guys
they're the big important numbers in
math now ready for me this is just a
side note just a little thing turn funky
out of them better these numbers they're
not just randomly connected and cool
right if you take 80 unfortunately your
calculators countries unless you have a
pic if you have an F X 100 you might but
if you raise it to the power of Pi you'd
expect that to be a weird number right
oh if you raise it to the power of I
times pi get that yeah you probably
don't have my calculator I mean what you
know it'll spit you back in math era
it won't do it so what's this about he's
a weird numbers so in summary
you know all these other here these are
what we call the algebraic numbers the
numbers we can build without turning
these numbers over here they come from
they come from somewhere else we didn't
make these things we didn't design this
is everywhere in the universe it sort of
it transcends the tools that we have for
building numbers which is why they're
called transcendental numbers let me say
that again you got all these numbers
over here this huge family of numbers
that we can build through algebra and
then you've got these reared guys who
they are real obviously we're not not
this kind of real are there there's some
kind of number but they transcend the
tools that we have for building on this
the transcendental numbers okay now
they're not the only ones in pi but
they're the most famous ones